the suicide squad brings a whole bunch
of fascinating
little-known dc characters to the silver
screen one of them is peacemaker a
warrior who loves peace so much
he'll kill to protect it his story only
gets weirder from there
and we're here to break it down for you
first things first
who is peacemaker the central idea of
peacemaker is that he's an incredibly
devoted pacifist
so committed to the cause in fact that
he's willing to hurt countless people to
achieve it
that's right he will wage war to win
peace he loves peace
and he's willing to kill together and
that's pretty much it
though there are a few different
incarnations of the character
christopher smith his original
incarnation is the peacemaker most fans
know
and the one relevant to the suicide
squad smith was once a spy who worked to
promote
the cause of world peace by sneaking
into various countries to fight warlords
and dictators
he debuted in issue number 40 of the
fight in five way back in 1966 as the
backup story and then continued
in his own comic which lasted all of 5
issues
peacemaker was created by charlton
comics heavy hitters
joe gill and pat boyet though many of
their other characters have gone on to
fame and fortune peacemaker hasn't been
quite
so lucky though some undoubtedly loved
him he ended up being a lesser known
superhero from a lesser known comic book
publisher
until dc comics purchased a huge swath
of tarleton comics characters in the
early 1980s
while it's incorrect to say that the dc
purchase brought peacemaker out of
obscurity it did save him from a
totally trivial fate having purchased
charlton's characters dc began to
incorporate them into their expansive
and
frequently rebooted universe while
characters like blue beetle and captain
adam gained a new lease on life in dc's
pages dc's attempt to revive peacemaker
wasn't terribly successful on its own
terms
dc's 1988 reboot took peacemaker out of
the sparkling silver age of comics
and into the grit and grime of the late
80s the short series pitches
peacemaker's absolute commitment to
peace as a mental illness
he suffers from extreme trauma and guilt
as his father was a nazi concentration
camp commander to make matters worse
peacemaker's father committed suicide in
front of him when he was just a child
and the moment has stuck with him ever
since
carrying his father's guilt and
traumatized by his death peacemaker is
committed to stopping the next hitler by
any means necessary
if that's not enough darkness for you
consider this this peacemaker
is haunted by the people he's killed
their ghosts including his fathers
speak to him from inside his space-age
bubble helmet
combined with his new backstory it's
heavily implied that the ghosts are
nothing more than a manifestation of his
mental illness but this fact doesn't
really lessen the grim
shadow they cast over this reboot the
1988 peacemaker reboot
didn't make much of a splash far and
away the most
likely reason comic book readers today
might have heard of the peacemaker in
fact
is a comic book that doesn't even
involve him we're talking about watchmen
the legendary comic series that is
almost single-handedly responsible for
an entire generation of cynical bubble
popping takes on the superhero
alan moore and dave gibbons inversion of
comic book myth making didn't spring
fully formed from anyone's head though
they used the dc owned charlton comics
characters as their basis for watchmen's
super super-powered fascists
degenerates and madmen originally the
plan was to use the charlton characters
directly
and alan moore's earliest vision of the
series revolved around the mystery of
peacemaker's death
uncomfortable with sending the charlton
characters to such a dark fate dc
persuaded more into swapping them out
with original creations
thus the watchmen cast was born with
their charlton heritage
still very much intact the question
morphed into the deranged rorschach
silk spectre is a combination of
nightshade and phantom lady
and peacemaker became the comedian one
of the most well-known characters of the
entire series
stripping away even the thinnest
pretense on peacemaker's part
moore built a terrible attack dog who
can be sicked on
anyone threatening american supremacy
comic creators weren't content to let
peacemaker become a footnote
in future hardback editions of watchmen
the character reappeared in the late 80s
joining the dc catch-all spy
outfit checkmate appearing in that book
and suicide squad as part of the late
80s
janus directive crossover event this
storyline sees dc's various intelligence
organizations manipulated into fighting
each other
it's a twist-filled storyline and
peacemaker is right in the middle of it
yet again however his run in the comics
proved to be short-lived even if he
survived that particular suicide squad
adventure
that said at least he goes out in
dramatic fashion this time which is more
than we can say for his earlier runs
in an attempt to stop the evil plans of
the villain eclipso peacemaker crashes
his helicopter into the villain's tanks
seemingly dying for good in a fiery
explosion in 1993's eclipso number 13.
for a while it looked like someone new
would take up the mantle of the late
peacemaker
a man named mitchell black dons a
similar costume and swipes the
peacemaker's motives in 1999's living
assault weapons number one
rather than being haunted by lingering
nazi guilt black is a disgraced former
doctor who was stripped of his license
after
accidentally killing a young patient he
soon meets the same fate as his
bubble-headed predecessor however dying
during the 2005
infinite crisis crossover event because
comic book logic doesn't hold to our
real world standards it is later
revealed that peacemaker number one
christopher smith is actually still
alive
he enjoys quite a bit of spotlight in
the 2000s blue beetle series
becoming a mentor figure to young jaime
reyes and a more self-actualized person
than he'd ever been before
confusingly there is yet another
peacemaker of uncertain origin running
around the modern era of comics
this peacemaker only shows up in 1994's
justice league international number 65
and justice league america number 90
and appears to be neither smith nor
black so
who is he well he's a member of the
league busters who are apparently backed
by the un
and that's all we know he's never shown
up since
the multiversity was yet another chance
for comic book legend grant morrison to
get weird as all get out
the 2014 series sees a threat from
outside of dc's multiverse put the
entirety of the dc cannon in danger of
destruction
in a series of one-offs and two
collaborative stories
c-list superheroes from all over the dc
universe attempt to band together across
parallel timelines to stop these
outsiders these different planes of
reality communicate with one another
through comic books as the real
superheroes of one timeline are
fictional in
others peacemaker turns up in the
multiversity pax americana
number one set on earth 4 in earth
inhabited by the creations of tarleton
comics
in pax americana peacemaker follows his
commitment all the way to assassinating
the president of the united states
it's fair to speculate that john cena
will take peacemaker in a different
direction when he dons the bubble helmet
for the suicide squad in a featurette
for the film
cena describes the character as the
douchey captain america
given that punchy summation cena's
comedic acting chops and the outright
ridiculousness of peacemaker's core
character design
it seems likely that the movie will use
his deranged take on peacekeeping for
more than a few laughs
from a bird's-eye view of the dceu as a
whole we can't say we blame them
suicide squad with its gritty aesthetic
and self-righteous baddies
ended up being controversial to say the
least might as well get a little goofy
with the dude who kills for peace right
expect peacemaker to be the butt of
several jokes and a far cry from the
deranged and guilt-ridden nazi
descendant who chatted with the ghosts
of
everyone he'd ever killed while that
peacemaker was trying to make genuine
peace in the world and with his demons
it seems like cena's peacemaker will be
using the olive branch mentality as a
fig leaf
for heinous actions oh and you should
also expect to see more of him be on the
film
cena will get to live on in some form
thanks to a new hbo max spin-off series
written by the film's director and
screenwriter james gunn
gunn was pretty much given free reign to
do whatever he wanted with the squad
characters for the film and it's pretty
clear dc likes what they've seen
as part of dc comics line wide event
infinite frontier
in 2021 suicide squad was relaunched
with christopher smith the original
peacemaker fronting a new version of
task force
x amanda waller is more ambitious than
ever in the new series
in suicide squad number five we learn
wallers using bloodsport to kidnap
meta-humans from different dimensions
bolstering her ranks
peacemaker's job in waller's plans is to
help her build a team
meant to rival the justice league and he
not only seems pleased to help but he's
just as cold-blooded as his new
benefactor
by the end of suicide squad number two
five of the team members under
peacemaker's command are dead and he
doesn't seem to care about it any more
than if they were insects he didn't
notice he'd stepped on
he even gets trapped in arkham asylum
during a deadly gas attack and makes no
attempt
at all to save any of the prisoners
security guards or other staff
all he cares about is the mission so far
the new comic book series has shown
peacemaker to be a fairly rare member of
the suicide squad
most task force x recruits would do
anything to get out from under waller's
boot
but not christopher smith in his
narration to suicide squad number two
peacemaker says he's grateful because he
and waller share quote
the same mission peace at any cost
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
dc comics are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]